joining me now is president trump's
personal attorney christina bob she was
at mar-a-lago mar-a-lago when agents
were rummaging through the former
president's residence christina thank
you for being with us tonight
now your reaction about the breaking
news
absolutely uh your reaction about the
breaking news tonight
about these supposed
nuclear documents
that
may have been in mar-a-lago and were the
cause for concern and for the urgency of
this search warrant in the washington
post tonight right well you nailed it in
your opening monologue this is what the
democrats do they don't have any good
reason for doing what they did the
pathetic presser
that merrick garland
held for three minutes was insufficient
so they had to create fear normally they
should come out with exactly what
happened and why and explain themselves
and if it was a good reason they they
would have solid ground they are not on
solid ground so they had to come up with
something that would potentially terrify
the american public into freely giving
up their constitutional freedoms you
know if they're if we are on the verge
of nuclear war giving up the nuclear
codes maybe it's acceptable that they
violated the president's constitutional
rights it was not acceptable and they're
trying to come up with reasons to make
it sound appropriate and make it sound
okay because they don't actually have a
good reason for doing what they did
okay so christina just so i'm clear
about this i want to be really clear
is it your understanding that there were
not documents related to our nuclear
capabilities or nuclear issues that had
national security implications in the
president's possession when the agents
showed up at mar-a-lago
that's correct i don't believe they were
and if they thought did you know for a
fact
do you know for a fact they weren't have
you spoken to the president about it
i have not specifically spoken to the
president about what nuclear uh
materials may or may not have been in
there i do not believe there were any in
there the legal team had done a very
thorough search and had turned over we'd
been very cooperative with uh the byte
administration and the doj and turned
over everything that we found that we
had so it's my understanding on very
good belief based on a thorough
investigation that there was nothing
there
so christina when you when you were
there and the agents arrived did you did
you
ask can i accompany you on this grand
journey through mar-a-lago and they said
no like how did that play out
i did i well i actually believed that i
could just follow them because that
seemed like the appropriate thing to do
so i just started to follow them and was
told i wasn't allowed to and i said you
know i'm the president's attorney here
on site uh no one else had arrived at
that time and said i i should have the
opportunity to observe your search and
observe what you're doing and uh they
basically said no and i you know i tried
to push a little bit but i'm not gonna
push too hard against the fbi so i
backed off but
at no point during the day did they let
me follow them or accompany them
throughout the property
now christina the president has been
given until 3 p.m tomorrow to decide
whether he wants that warrant unsealed
what if anything can you tell us about
that decision-making process you know of
course the left is saying well if he
wants to be so transparent why doesn't
he just get it all out there and and
you're responsible sure
yeah well my response is it's president
trump's decision and he can make that
when he's good and ready to do it but i
want to remind everybody that it is the
biden administration that owes this
country an explanation not president
trump it was the biden administration
that took an egregious step to violate
constitutional rights of a president of
the united states and invade his
personal residence and now they want to
try to shirk that responsibility by just
saying well why doesn't he release it no
no they owe us an explanation and they
can't get out of it that quickly and i'm
sure uh president trump is going to make
his decision and i know that he bases
his decision on what he believes is best
for the country and what will bring us
together and unite us and i'm sure that
that is the driving factor for his
decision
christina the the scuttlebutt because it
always changes yesterday it was that
merrick garland knew nothing about the
raid that was hilarious and then today
they sent him out to say trust us and
everyone's being mean
and now it's there's a secret service
agent perhaps
that's the one that saw this this
nuclear or whatever material and he and
he or she is the one that's helping
establish that probable cause for the
warrant tonight what can you tell us
about the secret service detail that was
assigned to president trump and concern
that that may have been what
got this going yeah i don't believe that
for a second i think the secret service
has a lot of professionalism and i don't
believe for a moment that the problem
with this is on president trump or
anyone in his circle i think it's a
story that the leftist media wants to
try to
paint the picture that somehow there's
division within the trump camp there's
not and uh to the extent that they think
there's an informant or uh you know some
other type of division that is causing
this i'll i'll believe it when i see it
i'll reserve that judgment but i i think
this squarely falls on the shoulders of
the biden administration and i want to
see what they got because i don't think
they have enough for their actions well
they're certainly changing their story
quite a bit in like a 72-hour period uh
christina when they were in mar-a-lago
now you know i i know the layout of
mar-a-lago i've been to mar-a-lago
did they did they focus their search in
the president's private quarters it's a
big club i mean it's a there's a lot of
space there or did they go all over the
entire club because that's a lot of
rooms and it's a lot of you know a lot
of ground to cover and they had 30
agents or so i know
right so they told me that they were
specifically looking at three areas they
were looking at the presidential office
they were looking at the residents the
private family residents and then uh the
storage unit that we've heard so much
about you know on the bottom floor so
those i believe the search was contained
to those three areas that's what i've
been told i have no reason to believe
that they went anywhere else but because
i didn't accompany them you know i can't
say for certain but i don't think they
went anywhere else
i want to play a moment christina from
the attorney general today watch
the department does not take such a
decision lightly
where possible it is standard practice
to seek less intrusive means as an
alternative to a search and to narrowly
scope any search that is undertaken
christina is there any reason then
legally
why he can't tell us why a search became
necessary
right that's a really nice sound bite
and i think that that's how they're
campaigning and you know that's how
they're running the administration
because we we were cooperating with them
we met with them i was there when they
came in june and uh president trump
himself met with them you know briefly
and said hello and said anything you
need and he pointed to the attorneys
there and said anything they need make
sure they do it and we had been
cooperating to the fullest extent and
that from that meeting in june the next
thing i heard was on monday where they
said you got to get down to mar-a-lago
they're reading the place and i thought
well that's odd because we had just said
if you need anything else let us know
so i i i don't i i don't believe his
statement it sounds really nice and it's
a good principle that we should live by
but they don't
now the the much much was made about the
safe you know the the safe cracker and
so forth but
do we know was there anything in the
safe was it much to do about nothing
with the safe did anyone even know how
to open the safe what do we know about
it
well i love the story because i actually
couldn't i couldn't accompany them and
so i couldn't see it i couldn't see what
they were opening so we we know about
the story because of the cctv than the
cameras were on and so uh those in new
york watching were were aware so i have
to take their word for it i know the
president put the story out so i have no
reason to believe it didn't happen but i
wasn't able to witness it because i was
pretty much relegated to the parking lot
no so when when you were speaking with
the fbi agents and those agents at the
time were they cordial were they
you know you can get a sense of
someone's kind of embarrassed that they
have to do something always just like
yeah thank you move aside like
right well initially
initially it started out a little uh
heated simply i mean i was upset and you
know they were not excited to see me so
we had a little bit of an incident
initially uh just me wanting access to
the warrant they didn't believe they
needed to even show me the warrant so we
thought about that not for very long
maybe a minute no more than two and i i
did have an opportunity to see it they
didn't give it to me and then after we
kind of worked through that you know it
was a long day so you know there's no
point in keeping it heated for too long
so only for a couple minutes there was a
little bit of tension and then it calmed
down for the most part and everything
was fine i they wouldn't allow me inside
anywhere so i had to stand out in the
heat for i don't know eight to eight
hours or so maybe nine hours and so
eventually they were kind and offered me
water uh because i was out there but
i would have appreciated the opportunity
to wait in air conditioning
yeah did they did they give you the
inventory list before they left or while
they were doing the raid that they don't
want to call a raid
right the raid uh we do have the
inventory list as you can expect uh it's
not particularly helpful
uh so
yes i kind of have the inventory list
they gave me the official receipt um but
you're gonna give it to us tonight
christina we're happy we're happy to
we're happy to talk tonight for the next
40 minutes on the show yeah well i would
love to christina christina we really
appreciate your joining us
uh you're a young lawyer and you were
put in a
uh one of the most historic and i think
egregious uh abuses of federal authority
that i've seen in my legal career a long
long time but we really appreciate your
joining us tonight and answering some of
these questions hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else